(audience cheering)
- Did you- (laughs)
(laughs) You're like, hold up, hold up.
It never happened, it never happened.
- These are my pretty shoes.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Those are my really comfortable shoes.
- I am with you, I literally just found
a pair of comfy tennis shoes.
I think that's how you
know that you're getting
to the point where you just
don't care what people think.
It's like, I literally bought
them in six different colors
and it's all I wear, 'cause
my feet hurt sometimes.
- [Ted] My feet hurt a lot.
- But I can hear you
though, I have to wear a heel.
I don't have to, but people
expect women to wear heels.
- I know.
- Yeah.
- Are you doing that to
yourselves or is it us guys?
- I think a man invented them so...
(audience laughing)
And I think it was back in the
day for royalty, wasn't it?
So they appeared taller for the kings.
Wasn't it where heels kind of came-
Did I just make that up,
are we playing the game BS?
- No.
(audience laughing)
- I feel like if we're
playing the game BS...
- At least I'm not mansplaining
why you have to wear heels.
(everyone laughing)
- I know, I know.
I don't have to, which is the point.
But I do wear more comfy ones
now, I have platforms now.
How is Mary, I love your wife so much.
- She loves you too.
- [Kelly] She's so great.
- We'll say that to you in person someday.
(crowd cooing)
- How are y'all?
I love you as a couple.
Are y'all ever apart?
I feel like y'all are always together.
- We had two week rule,
but that that's gone.
It's like, she's gone
tonight and we're distraught.
- You're like, "What am I gonna do?"
- Yeah, it's not an awe, it's like
I've turned helpless to be honest.
(everyone laughing)
- It's a codependency, it's awesome.
So you recently got hearing aids.
So are you into this or not into this?
What are they in today? (laughs)
- I'm still a smidge
vain so they're not in
for our little tete-a-tete.
- Oh they're not?
- No.
- Wait, why be vain?
Wait, well what's new-
- No, no, I wear them, I love them.
I love my hearing aids they're brilliant.
They've changed my life.
- Yeah, what do you hear now
that you didn't hear before?
(audience laughing)
- All the wind that I break
that I used to think was-
(everyone laughing)
- You thought was so silent (laughs).
- (laughs) Mary would say,
"Ted, people can hear you".
I go, "Come on, they can't
hear me, of course not."
And the first time I went on, had them in
it was like, "Oh my God, I'm sorry".
- (laughs) For years.
- Yeah.
- Oh, you're that guy, that's amazing.
Well, speaking of breaking
wind I heard that you had a...
Is this true, a psychologist?
- And if you can't have fun
with a fart in a relationship...
- Farting is funny.
- Oh my God.
- I feel sorry for people.
(audience clapping)
- Farting is funny.
Everyone does it.
I heard that you had a
psychologist once tell you
for like theater or something
or on stage if you're nervous?
- We got outta Carnegie Mellon
University and we all went
to New York and it was
still like almost living
in a dormitory, but we all
used the same psychologists
'cause life was too scary at that moment.
Anyway, he told one of
us then it got around,
"You're too uptight, you should be farting
like a Jack rabbit.
(audience laughing)
Who knew about Jack rabbits.
- What?
- But that has become
our little family motto.
- Oh my God so you just crop dust people
on stage, you're just...
- I personally, no.
- Okay, or maybe-
- Woody Harrelson.
(everyone laughing)
Woody Harrelson.
- It was like its own
instrument in the Kelly song?
- Yeah and he was a vegetarian.
- Oh my, that's why.
- This is my chance to get Woody.
He would stand next to me and engage me,
and he was very cool guy.
And he would say, "Ted, I really want
your opinion on something."
And I'd be touched and I'd
move in closer to hear it
and give it my best shot.
And he would just be looking at my eyes,
like a murderer waiting for it to rise.
- For it to rise.
(everyone laughing)
- And see the whole horror
and dismay on my face.
- Oh my God, oh my God I love that story.
- That's Woody Harrelson.
- That's amazing.
That's horrible to to do to someone.
Especially when they breathe it in
and they're like, "I just ate
it, it's like." (wretches)
like no, gross.
Okay, there's no segue there.
So what is new this
season in on "Mr. Mayor"?
- First off we had a
blast doing it because
it didn't have the
desperation of the first year
of COVID and shooting
and go off and have fun
but don't die kind of thing.
(audience laughing)
- (laughs) Kind of trauma?
- And so this was very
exciting and joyful just
to be together and not have to wear a mask
all the time while we rehearse.
So it was very sweet.
So we were very content,
very happy to be together.
And what's new?
I think my character, the
mayor realizes that just 'cause
he wanted to prove to
himself and to his daughter
that he still had it at 73,
it's not a good enough
reason to become the mayor.
- Yeah, he's gotta follow through.
- Yeah, and so I hire a team of
the brightest minds,
young kids in California
to come be my innovation team
and they're horrible
and everyone hates them
and they make me do all sorts
of things like put my face
on trash cans with a big
hole where my mouth is.
(everyone laughing)
- Well, it's memorable.
- It is, and that was the point,
I had bad name recognition
so they thought this
would be the great way
to get me out there.
You have to see it.
(everyone laughing)
How funny it is.
- Let's talk about the cast.
We've had a few cast members
from the show on the show.
It's such a great cast.
- [Ted] It is.
- Is it a fun-
Do y'all have really good chemistry?
- Yes we do, and the
characters are written
by Tina Fey and Robert Carlock.
- Brilliant.
- And they're so extremely
different from each other
that when you put us all in one room
it's fun to watch how we have to react
and still love somebody who's
so not who you are, you know?
- Yeah, is it fun though,
to be that person?
You know what I'm saying,
it's kind fun to play-
- Well I was born for this part.
(everyone laughing)
- [Kelly] What does that mean?
- It means that I'm that
older, white rich guy
who should not still be in the game.
(everyone laughing)
- I have to typecast.
- Old white guys in a
position of power are like...
- Yeah, yeah.
Wait, so you're passionate
about the environment.
And I heard that you got into interested
in cleaning up oceans,
pretty big time right?
Is it back in the eighties?
- Yeah it was mostly coastal
pollution at that time
and offshore oil drilling and
trying to stop an oil company
from slant drilling into Santa Monica Bay.
And my friend and I, Bob Sulnick,
who was an environmental
lawyer naively kind of went,
"Let's start an
environmental organization".
And we did, and it was small,
but really well respected.
People weren't talking about it that much.
We had an office in Washington and here,
and then that merged into Oceana,
which is now the world's
largest ocean advocacy group
that focuses on oceans,
and it's brilliant.
- Which is amazing, yeah.
- Check out oceana.org, but it's-
- You should what you should
check out to scare you?
To scare you, look at polluted waters.
There is an entire area of
the ocean that runs for miles,
I feel like, with just trash
and that's just incredibly sad.
- Yeah, yeah it is sad and
terrible for the critters.
It's also part of the whole
climate change because you drill
for oil, you make plastics,
you da da, da, da.
So you're putting out all
these gases and the life-
- But all that affects not
just them, it'll affect us,
we're eating that fish.
All of it affects all of us and-
- Yes and it doesn't ever go away,
but it gets small and smaller pieces.
So yeah, it's not good.
- It's just amazing to me
'cause we can do much with
technology, we can do so much.
We're talking about going to Mars
but we can't just take
trash outta the ocean?
- We're gonna get there.
(audience laughing)
- Okay but isn't it kind of astonishing?
Yeah, it's astonishing to me.
- And it's usually for
a product that is made
to be used once.
- And then it's wasted and it's tossed.
- And then it's there in
the environment forever.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Not smart.
So we wanna make sure
that you have a choice
as a consumer when you
check out or you are dealing
with Amazon, they should
give us all a choice.
'Cause when you're given a
choice to do the right thing
for the environment, do it, they do it.
- people choose the right thing, yeah.
But you gotta have the
option, I agree, I agree.
Do you remember the first laugh
that you ever got on stage?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] You do?
- When was that?
And did you fart like the
psychologist told you to?
(everyone laughing)
- No, I'm still very uptight, I was not.
I wanted to be a basketball player.
- [Kelly] That makes sense, you're tall.
- Yeah and I was probably
a mediocre player,
but our little school
won the championship.
So my friend and I went to
Stanford and we both walked
onto the freshman basketball court
to try out for the freshman team.
And it was the same year that Lou Alshon
or Kareem was a freshman at UCLA.
And the game was, I was...
I did what I'm doing now and turned around
and walked off and had a good cry.
(everyone laughing)
- [Kelly] Oh no.
- Yeah.
And then about a few
months later I was asking
this girl out to have a cup of coffee.
I finally had the nerve,
her name was Beth and she said, "Okay".
And we went and had coffee
and five minutes in she said,
"I am so sorry, I have an audition
I have to go to for a play".
And I said, "Can I come?"
Just wanting to be with her.
And then to stay in the
room, I had to audition.
So I made something up and
people laughed and I went-
- You went up there with nothing?
- Yeah.
- Whoa, you liked her a lot.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, but I heard my
first laugh and it was like,
"Okay it's not basketball,
but it's pretty good".
- [Kelly] Felt good.
- Pretty, pretty good.
- So one dream died in other was born.
- Yep.
- See, there we go.
I'm glad that you were bad at basketball,
we would've missed out.